This episode was sponcered by Google Science Fair.
A near perfect sphere of hot plasma
with a core that's more than 15 million degrees Celsius,
the Sun is the most important source of energy for life on Earth.
But what if it suddenly disappeared for
one month? We were actually inspired to
think about this question by the Google Science Fair, which is an online global competition
for sharing your best ideas using Science, Technology,
Engineering or Math.
I mean, without the sun, we'd be required some
pretty extreme innovations to survive.
If you're between the ages of 13 through 18, and have an idea
of you think can shape our world no matter how big,
or small, unique, or improving
on an existing idea,  you could win an educational scholarship,
travel experiences, or tons of other prizes.
So stick around at the end of the video for more details.
Now after the sun disappears, for the first